and Constantin kissen himself likes to
offer advice to political leaders from
the outside and is unafraid to say what
might be unpopular he's a self-described
politically nonbinary satirist and
co-hosts the Free Speech podcast
[Music]
trigonometry the head of the British
army is urging the need to train up and
equip a citizen Army in view of a
potential land
War are we ready for World War I I
completely agree with Brahman that we
are in a very dangerous world but I
think the question we really should be
thinking about is why are we in a
dangerous World why does Vladimir Putin
feel comfortable to invade Ukraine uh
why do the the Iranian regime feel
comfortable to back the Hamas terrorist
to attack Israel to back the houthis to
attack our shipping and I think the
reason is we've forgotten the very basic
principle of war that human beings have
known for Millennia which is civis patch
and Parabellum if you want peace prepare
for war we need a strong deterrent and
I'm sorry Alex the nuclear deterrent is
not going to be enough we need a
professional Army of well-trained men
and women uh like the British have
always had we've we have a rich military
tradition in this country and one that
we must maintain so I don't think a
Citizens Army is answered to that we
need a strong military uh made up of
professional soldiers it's something
actually that the the UK is known for
around the world if you at the training
we're for example given to the
ukrainians that's one of the biggest
things the contributions the UK has made
is not necessarily the kit it's the
training for them to know how to use it
that has made the biggest contribution
and the other thing I'll I'll say about
this one of the things that I'm
concerned about is the politicization of
our Armed Forces one of the stories that
I think emphasized this for me recently
was a very courageous woman we don't
know her name and I actually would like
to have her on my show if she wants to
come on to talk about the fact that she
was forced to resign from the Royal Air
Force because she refused to implement
ment the orders of her superiors to
quote stop hiring useless white men we
are starting to introduce all these
stupid ideas about diversity and all
this nonsense into an armed forces I'm
interested in an armed forces that are
excellent that are good at their job and
are good at the one thing they're
supposed to do which is kill the enemy
that's what I want
okay Constantine so the original
question was should Rishi sunak be
replaced with someone else to save the
conservative party I mean you could dig
up the corpse of Winston Churchill and
reanim M it still wouldn't save the
conservative party there whenever the
next election happens the Tories are
going to get what they deserve which is
a massive drubbing they will lose lots
of seats they will lose lots of MPS and
that's because they have failed to
deliver the things they promised the
British people they promised to reduce
immigration to the tens of thousands
last year was over 600,000 they promised
to crack down on illegal immigration we
currently spend 8 million PS a day on
hotels for illegal immigrants how many
of you voted for
that all the hands go down I'm not
surprised to say can I can I just say uh
that more people in this audience uh
voted for the cons conservatives than
any other single party in 2019 let's not
say the majority in this audience but
just as a matter of fact voted they have
leted down their own uh voter base both
here in the South and in the red wall in
the north the small C conservative
voters in the red wall are not going to
vote for a party that has allowed this
uh they've kicked out all the people in
the party or removed them from Office uh
who were actually prepared to be honest
about the problem they faced like s
braan they are going to get the drubbing
that they deserve nobody can save them
and I and by the way there not to say
the labor are going to be any better but
that is what's going to happen Okay so
look I said just now that there are many
of you who voted conservative in 2019
and I know a number of you who also
intend to vote conservative the next
election so in the interest of balance
because I notic that there's a lot of
hands off of people who who clearly want
to have a go at the government and we'll
hear from you again as well is there
anyone here who wants to speak up for
Rishi sunak or speak up for the
government
F this is kind of my point this isn't
about rishy sunag the point is for the
last 14 years the Tories have failed to
deliver on the things forget about you
know whether labor are happy with them
the problem is they have failed to
deliver the things they promised their
own electorate and Rishi sunak is not
the problem the problem is the
conservative party okay well let's hear
from the man here that was B that was
basically my
point so Fiona you mentioned the
terrible case in Nottingham it's
actually quite unrepresentative of the
majority of knife crime in this country
is terrible case in which paranoid
schizophrenic was essentially allowed to
walk free after being violent after
being diagnosed by the way a foreign
citizen who should have been deported I
don't understand why he's still in this
country however uh in terms of knife
crime more broadly I mean yes of course
we should ban zombie knives and machetes
from being sold but the truth is the
politicians won't tell you is you're not
going to out police night knife crime
because it's not a police problem it's
not an issue of how many knives are
being solved we have the harshest knife
laws we've ever had and yet knif C
continues and the reason is that the
people who are stabbing each other
mostly young men mostly young men who
grow up in terrible terrible backgrounds
mostly young men who don't have positive
male role role models in their lives
mostly because their fathers are not
around to look after them and to guide
them onto the right path and until we
address the terrible breakdown of family
and community in this country this
problem is going to get
worse yesterday evening I was watching
the news with my 15-year-old who who
luckily isn't doesn't fall into the the
bracket you described and he really
expressed despair for the future um and
I don't think anything he heard this
evening would would improve that but the
question is what can we do to give hope
uh for a better future for our
children we can all do with that I think
we going about five minutes you have to
be reason briefly so Sonia how do we
create hope for a positive future for
for for for John's son and and all the
other young I want us to crack our house
in crisis because I think it's a blight
for young people people it's fine if
you've got parents with wealth who can
help you get on the housing ladder for
some young people there's no jobs in
their local area they can't no jobs of
prospects they can't move to where the
jobs are the way I would do it because I
think we're about Solutions now for your
15-year-old is we used to have Council
housing in this country that people were
proud to live in after the second world
war you know between one in three and
one in four people lived in Council
housing We Now call it social housing
that's the wrong term makes it sound
like a handout it's not a handout it's
decent housing for not for-profit rent
it's rent that doesn't go to lining the
pockets of landlords we need public
investment in housing again and we need
to give a guarantee if I were the labor
government we need to give give a
guarantee to people in their 20s you
will get a set number of years with an
affordable good quality rented
housing be quite brief Andre
con I think son is absolutely right on a
practical level but I think at a
cultural level is something perhaps even
more important which is we've got to
stop talking down our country I'm a
first generation immigrant to this
country and I get annoyed hearing people
talk endlessly about how we're the worst
country in the world we're the most
sexist country in the world we're the
most racist it's all nonsense this is
one of the best places to live in the
world and that's what we should be
talking about the fact
that shame well this is this is exactly
this is exactly the problem that I'm
talking about you are saying shame on
you for walking up Britain and that is
exactly the problem that we're talking
about this is one of the best places to
live in the world for minorities like me
it's the best place to woman to there's
no point in shouting out for the because
because the people at home can't hear
you so so and also let's not let's try
not hang on let's try not to talk over
each other I asked constant a question
we In fairness I have to let him answer
we've got to stop we've got to stop
talking down our country we've we've got
to stop shouting over people who are
I've got two minutes left and I have to
let the rest of the panel answer so let
me just do
that we do something about housing we do
something about climate change and we
tell young people I've got a 21-year old
daughter we tell them they're really
really nice people it is a great
generation that is coming Alex um I
think that there are uh Grounds for Hope
and there's a ground for Hope in a way
that I think automatically appeals to
young people and that is in the white
heat of technology that is coming that
you have uh the Advan in artificial
intelligence in Quantum Computing and
hang on hang on I know you want to make
your point wellex just wait one second I
know you want to make your point but we
we've been asked a question and that's
how this program works the panel answer
the question asked by CH so John so
that's what we're going to do please let
the panel answer please let the panel
answer the
question Alex I'm sorry please let the
panel answer the
question but this new technology um
stands uh the chance of radically
transforming uh our whole world by
creating very cheap energy and the
capacity to solve problems that we've
never had the capability to do so before
uh and I think that that is really
appealing to the Next Generation
Jonathan we got about 30 seconds left so
we can turn the page after 14 years but
let me say let me say this let me say
this I The Killing let me tell you this
the killing the killing the killing has
to stop we need a truce on humanitarian
grounds immediately and we need a
ceasefire a sustainable ceasefire that's
what we need now and a labor government
will work towards the creation of a
Palestinian State as part of a two-state
solution that is Hope okay right listen
our hour is up thank you for all your
questions I just want to say thank you
very much to joavan pomilio who supplied
the photographs here that you can see of
where we are in jilan tonight thank you
very much for all your questions really
appreciate you coming here tonight we
are in glasg next week and then of
course